de ce
matin avec une journée qui est consacrée
pour notre part
à à l'éducation avec cet après-midi vous
le savez l'audition de de Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse à
16h45 en salle mdicis et ce matin nous
nous recevons Laurent Champanet
président de la Conférence des grandes
écoles et Philippe choet président de la
physique Fédération des établissements
d'enseignement super rie d'intérêt
collectif pour évoquer l'évolution de
l'offre en matière d'enseignement
supérieur et et plus particulièrement la
part prise au sein de cette offre par
les acteurs privés je rappelle qu'en 20
ans le le paysage de l'enseignement
supérieur français s'est profondément
transformé historiquement occupé par
l'université et les grandes écoles il se
caractérise aujourd'hui par un un
foisonnement d'acteur et le dynamisme
d'une offre privée composée
d'établissement d'enseignement supérieur
privé non lucratif les espiges et
reconnu il y a 10 ans par la loi fiorazo
et je crois d'ailleurs que c'était à
l'issu d'un d'un amendement proposé par
une sénatrice que je salue Valérie
lettard avec cette occasion et
d'établissement privés à but lucratif
dont certains ont largement tiré profit
de la réforme du financement de
l'apprentissage je précise que
l'objectif de de cette table ronde et
cette matinée d'échange n'est pas
d'opposer le public au privé ou au sein
de cette seconde caté le le privé
lucratif au privé non lucratif il s'agit
plutôt grâce à votre connaissance du
secteur et votre expertise d'appréhender
les conséquences de cette évolution et
de comprendre les tensions qui sont
apparues ces derniers mois sur le sujet
il s'agit aussi d'apporter des réponses
aux questions légitimes des élèves et de
leurs familles qui se trouvent dans
l'incompréhension voire dans le désarroi
en constatant que les frais de scolarité
souvent élevés qui qu'ils ont déboursé
ne leur garantissent ni des formations
reconnues par l'État ni l'obtention de
diplôm leur permettant de poursuivre
leur études dans l'enseignement
supérieur il s'agit enfin d'entendre vos
réactions et d'écouter vos éventuelles
propositions concernant les les
premières annonces des pouvoirs publics
en ce domaine je pense en particulier à
la création d'un label de qualité pour
l'enseignement privé évoqué par la
ministre Sylvie rotaillot lors de sa
conférence de presse de rentrée ou de la
mise en place d'une plateforme forme
répertoriant les formations publiques et
les formations privées bénéficiant d'une
reconnaissance par l'État évoquée par
Annesophie BZ directrice générale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de
l'insertion professionnelle et soutenue
par la médiatrice de l'éducation
nationale et de l'enseignement supérieur
en un mot et comme d'autres en parallèle
nous souhaitons contribuer à dissiper le
flou et la confusion qui règne sur ce
sujet et dont nos étudiants et leurs
famillees peuvent être bien sûr les
premières victimes je vais vous laisser
la parole monsieur président non sans
vous avoir rappelé que cette audition
est est captée et diffusée en direct non
pas en direct en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat je vais vous laisser
la parole 10 minutes chacun puis après
bien sûr chacune des signénatrices et
des sénateur pourra intervenir en vous
posant des questions et revenir sur tel
ou tel point que vous aurez abordé ou
pas dans votre intervention
liminire merci monsieur le Président
merci à à vous toutes et tous de nous
accueillir donc je suis Laurent
champagel président de la Conférence des
grandes écoles et mon vrai métier c'est
directeur général de des Arts et Métiers
l'école d'ingénieur euh la Conférence
des grandes écoles c'est une association
loi 1901 qui regroupe 238 grandes écoles
euh je remercie mes collègues de la
phési d'avoir fait cette petite planche
qui est là euh donc il faut savoir que
les 2/ers de ces écoles sont des écoles
publiques donc il sont dans le dans le
panneau saumon qui est qui est là
complètement sur la gauche euh
de sous tutelle de 10 ministères
différents les principaux étant bien sûr
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche
mais aussi l'économie et les finances le
ministère des
armées le ministère de l'Agriculture de
la culture ainsi de suite voilà et le
tiers restant sont
euh des écoles non publiques mais qui
sont d'intérêt général qui sont ici
appelés Espig et EC les ESC c'est les
certaines des anciennes écoles
supérieures de commerce qui ont prend
qui ont pris un statut non associatif ou
non fondation et donc qui sont qui sont
d'intérêt d'intérêt général mais qui
sont pas qui sont pas exp et puis on a
un tout petit lot de moins de 5 écoles
qui sont hors
contrat dans la branche formation
formation contrôlée avec des diplômes
certifiés mais qui ne sont ni publs ni
ni Spig ou SSC voilà et qui en général
étit des écoles qui qui ont rejoint des
groupes des groupes plus grands voilà
nous ce qu'on constate effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président c'est l'apparition de tout un
tas d'acteurs nouveaux qu'on découvre
subitement sur des salons euh avec des
formations qui sont essentiellement
basées sur des titres RNCP euh et euh
avec une souplesse et une liberté
d'action que nos établissements n'ont
pas alors pourquoi parce que nos
établissements qui délivrent des
diplômes accrédit
certifié alors soit par l'état français
et ces organismes d'accréditation comme
la commission d'éti d'ingénieur
ou le ha comité d'évaluation de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
ou la
cfdg ou des ou des diplômes certifi
ont de par ces diplômes et ces
certifications ces accréditations
l'obligation autour de la
formation de mettre tout un dispositif
d'environnement qui permet
l'accompagnement des étudiants
accompagnement à la réussite euh la
partie ouverture internationale la
partie vivre ensemble lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes lutte
contre les addictions
euh les les tout un tas d'éléments qui
font partie de l'éducation des jeunes
puisque dans nos écoles on forme des
cadres donc des gens qui s'agit de
former un peu sérieusement pour devenir
devenir des encadrant dans dans des
entreprises euh et ces ces officines
qu'on voit se construire elles se
focalisent essentiellement sur la partie
formation euh sans équipes pédagogiqu en
faisant en ayant recours essentiellement
à des intervenants professionnels nous
ne remettons pas en cause les
compétences professionnelles de ces
intervenants mais ces officines ne
mettent pas en place tout cet
environnement qui est nécessaire pour la
formation des jeunes et qu'est-ce qui
leur permet d'exister et d'avoir une
certaine reconnaissance aujourd'hui bah
c'est une certaine confusion qui existe
entre des outils d'accréditation du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
des diplômes des des accréditations des
instances dont j'ai parlé avant et des
outils du ministère du Travail donc ça
fait longtemps titre RNCP c'est quelque
chose qui existe depuis extrêmement
longtemps le répertoire national des
compétences professionnelles ce sont des
outils du ministère du Travail à
destination des entreprises je suis une
entreprise je veux former un salarié je
cherche dans un répertoire à quelle
compétence je peux l'amener et comment
et quand je vais vouloir contractualiser
avec l'opérateur qui va faire la
formation je regarde s'il a le label
kaliopi qui a un label de sérieux des
processus mais c'est ces outils là
caliopi RNCP sont des outils du
ministère du Travail qui s'adressent à
des entreprises et aujourd'hui nous dans
nos écoles on a beaucoup développé
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage on a des
jeunes qui sont à la fois des étudiants
mais à la fois des salariés et donc du
coup on a des formations qui sont
accréditées mais qui sont inscrites au
RNCP et on a des des labels
callaliopi et ces officines ont détourné
ces labels du ministère du Travail pour
en faire auprès des familles des labels
de
qualité sur leur formation ce qu'ils ne
sont pas du tout et et du coup cette
confusion qu'il y a effectivement auprès
d'un d'un certain public de famille on
voit que les le public de ces
établissements là sont souvent des
catégories socio-professionnelles pas
forcément très élevés des parents qui
n'ont pas forcément fait d'études
supérieur qui qui ont des revenus qui
veulent le bien de de leur enfant et qui
sont prêts à financer ça ou ou à se
lancer dans l'apprentissage donc on est
très inquiet de cette de ce
développement là il y a des modèles
économiques derrière avec des
investisseurs qui sont très gourmands il
y a un modèle économique dans la
formation qui est tout à fait
particulier parce qu'une fois que vous
avez mis votre formation en place pour
un certain nombre d'étudiants tout
étudiant que vous rajoutez ce qu'il
payent c'est du bénéfice donc ça attire
les investisseurs donc on voit tout un
tas d'acteurs d'investisseurs nouveaux
qui arrivent sur ce marché là on se pose
la question de savoir d'ailleurs si ce
système là peut ne pourrait pas
redescendre à des niveaux plus bas de de
formation et on voit ce que vous
constatez sans doute dans vos
circonscriptions c'est des jeunes qui
sont partis dans ce système là en
pensant que c'est le même que celui qui
est sur la gauche ici et qui rencontre
telle ou telle difficulté il y a pas de
contrat d'apprentissage finalement donc
il faut payer ou l'entreprise
l'entreprise fait faillite je ne vais
pas bien j'ai des difficultés
psychologiques et dans ces officines
j'ai aucun encadrement je me retrouve
obligé d'arrêter ma formation et mes
parents ont payé pour rien et je suppose
que vous avez déjà eu des familles qui
se sont tourné vers vous pour demander
des explications pour ça voil donc nous
ce qu'on considère he c'est que on parle
de jeunes qui ont entre 18 et 20 ans
quand ils rentrent dans ces
établissements là qui sont en Phe
d'éducation on parle de formation
supérieure on forme des cadres des
cadres intermédiaires nous tout ce qu'on
fait dans nos formation en matière de
d'ouverture internationale de vivre
ensemble de diversité c'est fait pour
accompagner mes étudiants mais c'est
aussi fait pour former des cadres qui
vont avoir des influences fortes sur la
vie des entreprises et des organisations
plus tard et tout ce qu'on fait en terme
autour de la formation c'est utile pour
le développement de ces futurs cadres et
tout ça c'est absent des formations de
ces de ces officines donc nous on
considère que cette formation là qu'on
apporte elle est vitale pour la jeunesse
de la France et pour ses futurs cadres
et qu'il devrait y avoir de la
régulation dans le système pour qu'on ne
puisse pas
former ce type ce type de de de personne
sans tout cet environnement de formation
sans toute cette qualité de formation
qui est importante et encore moins avec
un financement public indirect à travers
à travers l'apprentissage donc on
souhaiterait qu'il y ait une régulation
sur l'ouverture de tels organismes de
formation voilà un petit peu ce que je
voulais vous dire et je répondrai à vos
questions après merci Monsieur ch
monsieur Chok oui donc bonjour à merci
monsieur le Président bonjour à à toutes
et tous donc voilà quelque part nous
sommes honorés qu'une des premières
session des sénateurs des nouveaux
sénateurs voilà porte sur l'éducation
qui est quand même une mission
essentielle pour notre pays qui est une
mission régalienne de l'État et et dont
on constate au fait que il y a une
libéral libéralisation qui peut qui peut
nuire en fait à sa qualité hein et donc
ça voilà je trouve très important qu'on
puisse échanger sur ce sujet alors
essayer de vous présenter simplement ce
secteur qui s'est beaucoup complexifié
au cours des des dernières années et
n'est pas évident donc tous les chemin
seront approximatifs mais on a essayé au
niveau de la physique de de vous faire
cette cette présentation donc avec
effectivement cette segmentation qui
sépare les établissements qui sont en
contrat avec l'État c'est-à-dire qui
s'inscrivent dans la mission de service
public de l'État qui sont évalués par le
Haut comité d'évaluation de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
qui sont évalués par différentes
structures teles que la Commission du
titre d'ingénieur ou la fndg pour les
écoles de de de
management et ces établissements sous
contat avec l'État donc sont soit
effectivement publics soit effectivement
des zespig établissement supérieur privé
reconnu d'intérêt général voire quelques
EESC et puis il y a ces autres écoles
voilà don dont on ne porte pas de
jugement sur la qualité à priori hein
mais qui se positionne hors contrat donc
qui n'assume pas cette mission de
service public pour beaucoup ce sont des
structures à but lucratifs hein voilà
dont la finalité de gagner de l'argent
mais c'est tout à fait loable il y a pas
de problème par rapport à ça la la seule
question est euh le jeunne au milieu de
cela comment s retrouve-t-il quel
investissement moyen long terme et
quelle évolution moyen long terme de de
de ce secteur hein par rapport à à
l'offre globale de l'enseignement
supérieur donc par rapport à à ce cette
segmentation donc la physique
effectivement est la principale
fédération des espique puisqu'elle
regroupe une une trentaine
d'établissements d'enseignement
supérieur à la fois école d'ingénieur
école de management école de commerce et
école en sciences humaines et sociale ou
école d'art donc moi-même je suis
directeur général de de de l'Institut
polytechnique unilassal voilà qui a qui
relève à la fois du ministère de
l'Agriculture et du ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et qui a 170
ans donc la contractualisation entre
l'État et et des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur est ancienne
hein puisqu'elle est ça quasiment été
créé concomitamment à la création des
des des grandes écoles spéciales créées
au moment de la Révolution voilà donc ça
c'est le le paysage des espigs donc les
espigs c'est un label qui a été créé
dans le casadre de la loi F Raso en 2013
justement pour bien marquer la
différence entre des établissements
reconnu d'intérêt général s'inscrivant
dans la la mission de service public et
d'autres établissements voilà qui ne
respectent pas les règles avec des
obligations he pour les établissements
qui sont à Spig à au-delà de la mission
de service public par exemple
l'obligation de présenter leur formation
dans dans parcours sup euh qui a
beaucoup d' créé aujourd'hui on pourrait
y revenir éventuellement dans dans CRE
de vos questions des obligations voilà
de s'inscririv dans la mission de
service public voilà actuellement il y a
tous les enjeux de transition écologique
et
sociétal là récemment il y a eu il y a
un problème au proche- Orient on on nous
demande d'avoir des des attitudes voilà
on s'inscrit complètement hein dans la
politique publique et et ça ça me semble
être important à à signaler alors si
aujourd'hui on est par parmi vous c'est
que il y a effectivement au cours des
dernières années l'enseignement privé à
but lucratif qui s'est fortement
développé alors vous allez me dire mais
pourquoi comme ça d'un seul coup il y
a le l'arrivée de de de ces structures
qui peuvent être soit très grosses comme
comme Galileo ou beaucoup plus
petites donc alors qu'on qualifie
quelque fois d'officine donc en fait ces
structures ont bénéficié d'un double
appel d'air l'appel d'air en fait de la
formation par
apprentissage qui est tout à fait
légitime l'apprentissage dans
l'enseignement supérieur est très ancien
il y a plus de 30
ceci étant en fait il a connu un
phénomène d'accélération lié à une
volonté politique et qui est tout à fait
louable c'està-dire de de de
professionnalisation de l'enseignement
supérieur et et pour certains types de
public ou pour certains besoins
d'entreprise voilà d'y d'y répondre
voilà l'autre donc mais et également un
financement beaucoup plus généreux hein
donc ça c'est un point qui me semble
important l'autre élément aussi
significatif qui a contribué à cet appel
d'air en fait c'est le la
les besoins les pénuries dans certains
certaines filières professionnelles en
fait d'emploi hein et donc les
entreprises prêtes à recruter un
étudiant postbac en apprentissage parce
qu'ell n'arrient pas à à à recruter dans
leur secteur et donc une très grande
facilité à placer des étudiants en
apprentissage l'un additionné à l'autre
a créé un appel d'air important plus les
subventions type les 6000 € d'aide à
l'emploi dans les dans les PME en fait
qui était gagnant à la fois pour les
entreprises mais également gagnant pour
les structures qui se créent avec des
niveaux de rentabilité et c'est là où le
bas peut blesser c'està des niveaux de
rentabilité très élevé plus c'est deux
chiffres et le premier chiffre n'étant
pas un voilà euh et et et donc comme un
C ce secteur avait un taux de
rentabilité très élevé bah des des
capitaux des qui se sont intéressés à ce
secteur très rentable et donc une
financiarisation euh de de cette
activité
en France alors ça existait déjà dans
d'autres pays notamment en Amérique du
Nord mais ça voilà c'est ces capitaux se
sont déportés vers vers la France du
fait de ce contexte hyper favorable
alors on n'est pas à opposer
enseignement public enseignement privé
enseignement privé à but non lucratif
enseignement privé à but lucratif je ve
dire il peut y avoir de la qualité
partout là-dessus faut pas qu'on qu'on
se méprenne en revanche c'est vrai que
le très fort développement de cet
enseignement privé à lucratif
très peu régulé comme le disait Laurent
Champanet en fait peut avoir des des
effets très négatifs en fait sur sur
notre système éducatif donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on constate quand même un
développement anarchique parce que il y
a très peu de régulation quant à la
création de ce type de structure alors
vous allez me dire bah oui mais comment
font-ils par rapport au diplôme mais en
fait aujourd'hui vous pouvez louer des
diplômes donc si vous êtes
intelligent des titres pardon oui des
titres vous pouz des titres c'estd si
vous êtes intelligent vous avez un bon
réseau professionnel vous créez votre SL
ou SS vous louez un titre à des
structures qui se sont spécialisé dans
la loocation de titrre RNCP et vous
créez votre entreprise et et à des
niveaux de rémunération tels que proposé
par France compétence qui sont très
élevés l'autre point en fait qui peut
être très préjudiciable en fait c'est la
la qualité de certaines de ces
structures je ne dis pas toutes de
certaines ces structures parce qu'en
fait le le système de contrôle qualité
opéré par les OPCO hein c'est les
structures qui qui financent et qui sont
les intermédiaires de France compétence
en fait sont à ce stade pas suffisamment
développés et aujourd'hui en fait ce qui
fait quand même la qualité d'un d'un
enseignement et et du système éducatif
c'est un taux d'encadrement donc c'est
un nombre de salariés permanents par
rapport à des étudiants qui leur sont
confiés c'est d'autant plus important
quand vous êtes en postback donc quand
les les étudiants sont jeunes c'est d'
d'autant plus important quand vous
voulez ne pas être discriminant par
rapport à des jeunes qui sont ici
situation modeste et on sait le rôle
d'un professeur pour tirer vers le haut
des jeunes et cette mission d'éducation
ne peut pas être déléguée à l'entreprise
l'entreprise n'est pas philanthropie
n'est pas philanthropique le le la
mission d'une entreprise lorsqu'elle
accueille un apprenti c'est de le former
à ses propres besoins et en aucun cas de
le former pour que demain il il puisse
évoluer dans son métier pour que demain
il puisse aller travailler dans une
reentre
ça c'est pas la finalité de de
l'entreprise donc par rapport à ça le
taux d'encadrement est un point
essentiel et c'est vrai que dans ces
structures autant dans nos école
d'ingénieur par exemple
voilà la Commission d' d'ingénieur nous
impose un taux d'encadrement de 1 pour
20 c'està-dire à peu près quand vous
mettez les administratifs c'est à peu
près un un salarié permanent pour 10
élèves dans ces structures officine
voilà vous pouvez être à un salarié
permanent pour 100 200 étudiants voilà
avec une forte délégation aux
entreprises par rapport ort à ces cette
mission d'enseignement
professionnel et puis un suivi qui peut
être très aléatoire et donc une qualité
qui peut être préjudiciale derrière ça
aussi il peut y avoir des externalités
négatives he c'estàdire que le propre de
l'enseignement par apprentissage il est
très courttermiste il répond à un besoin
très court terme des besoins des
entreprises très court terme voilà de
intéressant par rapport au jeunes mais
le diplôme que re enfin le titre que
reçoit le jeune n'est pas un diplôme
pour faire pas un grade universitaire et
ne permet pas la poursuite d'études euh
de de niveau Bachelor enfin au licen ou
ou ou ou ou de niveau Master et donc
quelque part c'est très courttermiste il
y a pas obligatoirement les fondamentaux
qui demain permettront à des jeunes
d'évoluer voilà et donc ça tire
inévitablement l'enseignement supérieur
vers le bas voilà alors on on on on se
plaint beaucoup en France que voilà le
système éducation nationale le niveau
baisse il faudrait pas que
l'enseignement supérieur soit également
attiré vers le bas parce que ces
structures qui sont très compétitives
qui essayent d'attirer des étudiants qui
essayent de déstabiliser le système euh
bah tire l'ensemble du système vers le
bas c'est-à-dire que le pour attirer les
élèves c'est vrai que l'essentiel de la
concurrence se fait au niveau du
recrutement avec
quelquefois des propos ou des des
arguments commercial qui sont voilà qui
sont qui induisent les les familles en
erreur et et à for les familles qui sont
peu renseignées et c'est vrai que
derrière ça bah les les jeunes en fait
euh peuvent être attirés vers des
formations effectivement où ensuite il
ils ont à payer et et sans lendemain qui
ne leur permettront pas d'évoluer et
donc ça ça me semble être un un point
essentiel à intégrer bon après on aura
effectivement quelques euh
recommandations à faire mais qui
tiennent surtout à la régulation de ce
secteur qu'il est insuffisamment
aujourd'hui hein et et je pense qu'il y
a urgence voilà pour que pour que notre
système d'enseignement supérieur reste
voilà une référence au niveau
international merci alors je vais vous
passer la parole maintenant en
commençant par euh Stéphane piennoir je
précise il AV à l'ordre du jour ce matin
la la désignation des rapporteurs nous
le ferons cet après-midi avant
l'audition de de Gabriel hatal donc ce
n'est pas au rapporteur que je passe la
parole mais c'est à Stéphane piennoir
voilà il va prendre la
parole merci monsieur le président
Messieurs les Présidents merci pour pour
ces propos et et ce panorama je dirais à
la fois utile je pense pour pour
l'ensemble des des collègues et
éclairant sur sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans l'enseignement
supérieur public et privé on a donc
précédemment quand j'étais encore
rapporteur eu l'occasion de de
travailler sur ces sujets assez assez
longuement je rejoins ce que vous avez
dit à un moment donné l'intérêt de tous
les acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur
c'est bien évidemment la qualité des
formations et des titres qui sont
délivrés ce qui nous importe à tous
c'est d'avoir des étudiants formés qui
puissent s'insérer dans d'excellentes
conditions qui puissent participer à la
à la richesse du pays je vais le dire
comme ça et et c'est bien de de cela que
nous discutons nous sommes amenés à à
discuter aujourd'hui alors plusieurs
questions par rapport à vos à vos
propos bon j'ai entendu que vous parliez
de de régulation vous réclamez de la
régulation par rapport donc à toutes ces
écoles hor contrat qui par définition
sont hor
contrat donc quels sont vos vos piste
pour euh pour faire de la régulation
avec des établissements qui justement ne
ne ne s n'ont pas de non'ont pas de
critères imposés par l'État on peut
penser cependant je vous laisserai
évoquer mais au taux d'encadrement et
puis au conditions d'octroit des des
primes sur l'apprentissage puisqu'on
sait que c'est ce sont les nouvelles euh
les nouvelles procédures de de
d'apprentissage dans l'enseignement
supérieur qui ont boosté le
développement de ces formations dans
l'enseignement supérieur privé dit
lucratif deuxème question le ministère a
annoncé en en juillet donc pendant l'été
la mise en place d'une d'ici l'année
prochaine d'une plateforme répertoriant
les formations publiques et les
formations privées
délivrant reconnu des d'État et
délivrant de des titres et et il me
semble qu'il y a un cycle de discussion
qui doit être entamé qui a été entamé je
ne sais pas si c'est le cas est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur sur l'état des discussions
actuelles avec le le ministère trè
question
en fait sur sur l'éclairage comment
éclairer les familles et les étudiants
qui sont un peu par perdus vous avons
comme beaucoup d'ici j'ai été enseignant
moi-même et amené à à orienter à
aiguiller un petit peu le choix des
étudiants sur parcours sup et Dieu sait
si si ça n'est pas facile
comment faire en sorte que les familles
il trouvent un petit peu il voit un
petit peu plus clair dans ce
foisonnement de cursus avec ses titres
ses diplôme je peux vous garantir que
pour un certain nombre de famill c'est
pas du tout clair
et le distingo n'est absolument pas fait
pire l'absence de reconnaissance par
l'État est-ce qu'on a des pistes pour
pour signaler ça de manière plus plus
plus forte en gros comment rendre plus
lisible ces différents paramètres pour
que pour aiguiller au mieux le choix des
des famillees et des étudiants et puis
dernière question sur les effectifs que
et et et le la sonnette d'alarme qui a
été tirée pendant l'été sur les
effectifs dans les écoles notamment les
écoles d'bliss supérieur et notamment
les écoles de management qui peineent à
remplir leur leur ban c'est vraiment
très très significatif cette année avec
des alors des des des des parade he
l'ouverture de Bachelor le le la
proposition de
passerelle ma question c'est quel est
votre positionnement par rapport auutau
réservé aux classes préparatoires aux
étudiants qui sortent de classes
préparatoirees qui qui ont fait quand
même la spécificité de ces écoles de ces
grandes école donc quelle est votre
position est-ce que il y a il y a un
seuil en dessous duquel il vous semble
pas pas correct de descendre je vous
remercie je vais vous laisser répondre à
cette première série de questions puis
nous en prendrons d'autres
après merci monsieur le sénateur pour sa
question euh alors sur la question de la
régulation nous alors on a eu on a eu
cet échange on a été impliqué dans dans
la mission du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur sur sur ces
questionsl nous on considère que
l'éducation c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important qui qu'on doit confier
à des gens dont c'est le métier mais
c'est pas à vous que je vais l'expliquer
et que en terme de régulation on
pourrait exiger pour l'ouverture d'un
organisme de formation qui ait une
équipe pédagogique à minima et une
équipe d'encadrement qui puisse
permettre un certain encadrement de
qualité autour autour des autour auprès
auprès de ces jeunes alors en
particulier quand on s'adresse à des
jeunes la aujourd'hui on nous répond on
nous oppose la liberté d'entreprendre
bon voilà alors il existe des
professions régulées c'est pas forcément
là la question mais au moins d'exiger un
certain taux d'encadrement comme l'a dit
Philippe nous pour être accrédité pour
une formation d'ingénieur on a on a une
exigence de taux d'encadrement même si
j'ouvre un nouveau campus il faut que ce
sur ce campus je mette des enseignants
permanents je mette des personnels
adistra permanant donc on pourrait
exiger quelque chose du même type
euh on ne sait pas dire aujourd'hui
alors par rapport à aux travaux de que
que la ministre retaillo a lancé on est
les travaux n'ont pas encore de
réflexion n'ont pas encore commencé on
sa qu'on va être impliqué dans ces
réflexions la question de la plateforme
euh je dirais il existe déjà une
plateforme qui s'appelle parcours sup
parcours sup dans l'esprit de beaucoup
de gens c'est un système de sélection
dans le nôre c'est un système
d'information avec une information
homogène alors il y a il y a toutes les
filières postback il y a pas les
filières au niveau master mais déjà en
terme de il y a beaucoup de chos avec
une signal éthique avec des logos qui
permettent effectivement de préciser
tout les type de de reconnaissance donc
on n'est pas forcément sûr qu'il ait
besoin d'une autre plateforme est-ce
qu'elle va être complétée simplifié
voilà malheureusement et et c'est le
risque qu'on voit derrière la notion de
plateforme c'est que parce que parcours
sup est euh très décrié comme l'a dit
Philippe c'est devenu pour certains un
argument politique de savoir s'il faut
le garder ou pas le garder
euh ces officines font de ne pas être
dans parcours sup un argument commercial
en disant
ne vous inquiétez pas vous allez pas
mettre dans le TR vous allez pas vous
mettre dans le traumatisme parcours sup
nous on va vous répondre avant et la
réponse sera positive bien avant vous
aurez pas besoin à vous embêter voilà et
en promettant en promettant un contrat
d'apprentissage et c'est une fois que
parcours sub sera fermé qu'on dira aux
jeunes ah ben finalement l'entreprise
s'est retirée il y a pas de contrat
d'apprentissage donc tu dois payer tant
de milliers d'euros donc on n'est pas
vraiment sûr qu'une plateforme Vienne
aider les choses on devrait sans doute
renforcer c'est l'intérêt collectif
qu'il y a au sein de parcours su après
sur la question de label ce qu'on
comprend aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a un
travail qui une volonté de de travail
entre le ministère deement spur et le
ministère du Travail et c'est une bonne
chose pour éventuellement étendre la
notion de la notion RNCP et de rajouter
à ça l'environnement de formation et la
l'équipe pédagogique donc pour nous
c'est une très bonne chose c'est une
très bonne chose
si ça fait au final que
des organismes qui n'auraient pas cette
reconnaissance ne pourrai pas bénéficier
des crédits de l'apprentissage voil si
c'est simplement un label
supplémentaire certains trouveront le
moyen de contourner de décrier le label
et voilà aujourd'hui les arguments de
ces officine c'est auprès des jeunes
c'est on n pas de prof ils disent aux
jeunes tu t'entends bien avec tes profs
au lycée non ben chez nous il y a pas de
prof il y a que des professionnels voilà
donc c'est mieux il y a pas de diplôme
parce que les diplômes c'est be
maintenant c'est les compétences
professionnelles et c'est l'insertion
professionnelle à la fin voilà et
certains n'ont pas de locaux tout tout
tout est à distance voilà et puis on
leur dit il y a des coachs il y a des
coachs qui vont vous guider dans votre
formation donc c'est c'est ça le c'est
ça le modèle qui qui est proposé donc
voilà si si ce on est pour une extension
un rapprochement entre les travaux du
ministère de l'ement et les travaux du
ministère du Travail vers un label comme
ça si ça effectivement empêche certains
d'avoir accès au crédit de
l'apprentissage et alors sur votre
dernier dernière question sur la
question des classes préparatoires bon
pour nous les classes préparatoires
reste
euh reste quand même une
une un élément important de notre
recrutement effectivement on constate
comme vous l'avez dit que globalement
nous le discours qu'on a auprès de la
ministre c'est de dire notre système
dans nos écoles il y a de la place on
pourrait faire plus sans forcément
demander des financements
publ supplémentaire à travers les
contrats voilà on pourrait faire plus ce
qui nous manque à l'entrée c'est un flux
de jeunes qui veulent venir dans nos
écoles ces officines détournent une
partie de ce flux
clairement qu'on pourrait absorber nous
et effectivement
elle elle laisse entendre aussi qu'il
pourrait y avoir un système un système
de formation un peu souple un peu de en
mode coaching qui fait que ça jette le
discrédit sur des formations plus
exigeantes comme les classes
préparatoires nous ce qu'on estime c'est
qu'aujourd'hui Philippe l'a rappelé on a
un enjeu collectif qui sont les enjeux
de transition transition écologique qui
va falloir des cadres qui transforment
les entreprises et ces cadres il il va
falloir qu'ils soi particulièrement au
point pour faire les transformations
dont il y a besoin et on reste persuadé
que la formation exigeante des classe
préparatoire est très propice pour
former ces cadres là en complément
d'autres gens plus de terrain qui aur
auront suivi d'autres parcours de de
formation après sur la question de votre
question c'était c'est quoi le niveau
c'était c'est qu'est-ce que vous vouliz
dire exactement par là
c'est on voit que le le nombre de de
préparationnaires qui sont dans les
issus des classes prépar qui sont dans
les grandes écoles TS à diminuer quand
même de façon assez importante est-ce
que vous fixez un seuil en dessous
duquel on vous pouvez pas descendre euh
non on on se fixe pas de seuil c'estàd
que effectivement
nous on est on est confronté à une
grosse demande des entreprises
aujourd'hui nous dans nos conférences on
reçoit effectivement des filière
professionnell le nucléaire le numérique
l'industrie la banque l'assurance les
métiers du chiffre tout le monde vient
nous voir en disant on n pas assez on n
pas assez de jeunes donc effectivement
on a élargi nos bases de recrutement
parce que le flux qui qui rentre et donc
qui sort des prépas n'est pas en
augmentation donc c'est pas c'est pas
une volonté de de basculer sur un autre
mode de formation initiale dans nos
écoles hein c'est plutôt parce qu'on n
pas assez on n pas assez de monde et
malgré ça on en a toujours pas assez et
dans les écoles d'ingénieur le gros
manque c'est les femmes si on avait 50 %
de d'étudiantes on aurait les flux
suffisants pour répondre au besoins des
milieux
socio-économiques donc en fait on on
n'est pas en train de se fixer un seuil
en dessous duquel on on arrête
quoi en fait je vais reprendre les
jeend les différentes questions et par
rapport à la régulation je dirais ce ce
qui est important c'est quand même le le
jeune autant on peut réguler un secteur
commercial économique bon allez j'achète
une savonnette je me suis fait avoir bon
tant pis je rachète une autre savonnette
il faut savoir que l'enseignement
supérieur c'est quelque chose qui
impacte toute la vie du jeune et et sa
capacité à faire marche arrière est très
faible c'est que une fois que je suis
dans une formation mes parents se sont
mouillés pour que j'y sois
je vais pas commencer à cracher dans sur
la formation où je suis donc la capacité
à se plaindre que quelque chose ne va
pas est très faible et j'ai j'ai pas
tellement de comparatif donc c'est
d'autant plus important que l'État
régule cela voilà que voilà que le jeune
est expos et malheureusement les jeunes
issus de milieu modeste sont les plus
exposés en fait au aux sirènes de ces
structures habit lucratif parce que on
leur dit bah attendez vous avez le choix
entre un BTS publ où c'est quasiment
gratuit mais là chez nous c'est
complètement gratuit vous avez un petit
salaire puis si vous travaillez bien à
la fin vous êtes embauché ce ce ce
discours là il est voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui les BTS publes quasiment
gratuits avec des bourses et tout ça ne
remplissent plus pourquoi certaines
écoles publiques où l'université est en
baisse bah parce que ce discours il a
prise auprès de ceux qui sont les qui
ont les moins éléments de de
discernement et et je dirais ceux qui
sont voilà issus de famille voilà où on
accompagne le jeune de CSP voilà
peut-être plutôt favorisé ou ceux qui
connaissent bien les arcanes de
l'enseignement supérieur cela ne se
trompe pas et on les retrouve dans les
écoles dans les grandes écoles les
grandes écoles publi ou ou ou ou de
manière paradoxale on voit baisser le
nombre de boursiers et on se dit mais où
sont passés les boursiers mais ils se
font avoir sur ce type de système donc
la régulation est essentielle il faut
qu'il ait à la fois lisibilité et
contrôle voilà donc il faut clarifier le
le cadre
euh faire en sorte que voilà qu'on
mélange pas des écoles sous contrat avec
des école hors contrat euh bien redire
que parcours sup est un super outil
comme on le disait tout à l'heure et et
que N son que des écoles voilà qui sont
garanties par l'État sous contrat avec
l'État et que les autres écoles qui se
sortent de ce système c'est délibérément
pour pouvoir dire au mois de février
venez chez nous on a un nombre de plac
limité si vous faites pas le chèque vous
on vous garde pas votre place avec des
pratiques commerciales qui sont
complètement en fait euh
voilà qui prennent à contre-pied ce que
font 80 80 % des des établissements
publics et privés qui font du travail de
qualité et qui sont préjudiciables au
choix du jeune alors par rapport à la
lisibilité
oui un label peut-être intéressant il
faut qu'on en discute et qu'on fasse
très attention parce qu'il existe le
label Espig a déjà fait cette cette
différence il faut sans doute travailler
sur la plateforme alors on a une réunion
avec au niveau du conseil consultatif de
l'enseignement supérieur privé pour
discuter de de la plateforme il faut que
la plateforme soit efficiente
aujourd'hui il y a des il y a des
plateformes qui existent mais
sincèrement allez-y on voilà c'est c'est
hyper complexe et c'est un peu la jungle
donc faut faut avoir des des éléments
très faciles à à identifier pour les
familles derrière c'est également le
contrôle c'estàd comment
contrôle-t-on les structures qui font de
la publicité commerciale mensongère on a
eu plusieurs cas dans nos fédérations de
publicité commerciale mensongère on a
prévenu les minstères de de de tutelle
on a on a prévenu l'organisme
accréditeur et et et aucune réaction
donc si le fait de mentir m'expose à un
risque très faible si je mens au mois de
janvier sachant que parcours sub se
termine en avril et que je suis
sanctionné un rappel à l'ordre au mois
de mai voilà j'ai recruté sans aucun
souci avec de la publicité mensongère et
j'ai fait le job donc donc par rapport à
ça faire faire très attention euh donc
le il faut contrôler également tout tout
ce système de location que Laurent
évoquait tout à l'heure je dire on peut
louer des titres RNCP un titre
commercial c'est ce que tu évoqua tout à
l'heure Laurent et derrière je je vends
du management du
sport sans aucun contrôle sans aucun
contrôle qualité et et derrière ça voilà
faut faut être beaucoup plus rigoureux
alors je veux pas dire obligatoirement
remettre en cause le système de mise à
disposition de titre parce que certains
établissements avoir un titre RNCP est
une mécanique compliqué euh certains
établissements peuvent aider des plus
petits établissements qui peuvent être
sur des territoires à avoir des titres
RNCP qui correspondent à une vraie
réalité économique un vrai besoin
d'emploi sur les territoires donc je dis
pas qu'il faut casser tout le système en
revanche il y a certaines structures
spécialisé dans la loocation de titrre
qui font beaucoup d'argent très
facilement avec de l'argent public et ça
ça va pas régulation également à la
création dire on a vu euh euh naître de
multiples structures comme je je
l'évoquéis tout à l'heure partant de
rien je veux dire c'est de l'argent
public euh voilà un niveau de prise en
charge très très facilement c'est entre
8000 10000 € l'entreprise bénéficie
d'une subvention l'État ne peut pas
distribuer de l'argent public à des
structures qui se montent comme ça
quasiment sans aucun contrôle qualité
sans peu de contrôle sur le diplôme et
peu de contrôle parformance compétence
ou les OPCO sur les diplômes donc la
régulation c'est aussi au niveau de la
création de ces structures voilà on peut
pas faire n'importe quoi avec cette
mission aussi essentielle qui est
l'enseignement supérieur et éclairer les
familles donc là je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire un travail entre les les
différentes fédérations et et le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur je
pense et le ministère du Travail qui
sont directement concernés
euh par rapport à la question de des
écoles de management alors et et des
classes prépa il faut savoir on a très
peu de statistiques sur que deviennent
les étudiants postbac alors on se dit
oui il y en a beaucoup qui sont partis
sur des formations sur tit comme ça
relève du ministère du Travail c'est
plus le ministère de l'Enseignement sup
donc on on les perd des radars récemment
on a beaucoup parlé aussi des stratégies
d'évitement voilà donc plutôt que de
faire une une prépa école de commerce je
suis dans un bon lycée parisien je m' je
m'inscris à l'intituto d'emessa à Madrid
voilà où je crois il y a 800 français je
fais mes 3 années sympa dans un coup
dans un cadre agréable dans une des
meilleures écoles de commerce espagnol
et je suis repris à l' sec ou à deck
oretour j'ai évité la prépa j'ai un
super réseau relationnel voilà donc ces
stratégies d'évitement il faut qu'on les
intègre et et ça vient bypasser
directement en fait les classes
préparatoire alors on est pris entre
deux
éléments les jeunes aujourd'hui sont
plus les jeunes d' y a 10 ans voilà donc
ils sont un peu paumés dans leurs
orientations donc sensibles aux sirènes
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure euh le sens
de l'effort à forceuie post covid c'est
plus obligatoirement celui que nous
avions donc le le système des classes
prépa et puis par ailleurs VO là il y a
les ce que j'appelle les pouf school
voilà vous faites la journée porte
ouverte il y a des poufs des billard et
et la salle de poste c'est une salle de
jeux vidéo ah ben les jeunes voilà qui
savent pas trop ils se dirent ah bah
cette école et sympa voilà alors c'est
il y a pas de prof mais il y a a il y a
des gens très avenants qui les
accueillent donc c'est po school c'est
le contraire de l'exigence voilà mais
nos entreprises du nucléaire nos
entreprises tout toutes ces
relocalisations qu'on veut faire les
jeunes ont un besoin d'un bagage minimum
qu'pporta avant les classes prépa ou les
ou les classes prépa intégré dans
certains établissements comme l'in les
UTC ou certaines écoles d'ingénieurs
privés qui avaient des classes de des
classes pr des classes prépa intégrées
par rapport à ça oui le niveau
d'exigence monte et il faut qu'on qu'on
accueille dans nos écoles d'ingénieur
qui sont
exigeantes tous les étudiants et de
toute diversité sociale aussi je le
redis parce que ce système il attire
malheureusement des des jeunes de milieu
plus modeste et et non ces jeunes ont
des capacités et il faut pas qu'on leur
raconte des sornettes et et qu'ils
viennent dans nos dans nos filières
d'excellence pour alimenter nos secteurs
économiques qui demain auront encore
plus besoin de je dirais de de de
connaissance de compéten et avec
l'arrivée de tout ce qui est
intelligence artificielle et tout ça
aussi de soft skill justement qui sont
pas obligatoement travaillés dans dans
dans ces structures qui sont vraiment
courttermistes merci et je vais prendre
toutes vos questions et puis je précise
pour nos nouveaux collègues que je vais
commencer par prendre un représentant
par groupe mais quand un groupe a deux
questions enfin ou deux intervenants
bien sûr il pourra également deuxème
personne pourra également intervenir
dans l'ordre Yan Chantrel Jean ingret
Pierre ouillas Monique dearco Bernard
fialer Max Brisson et ensuite David r
Samana casbon aussi pardon oui oui
Samantha casbonne David Ross et
Pierre-Antoine Lévi
oui oui merci merci monsieur le
Président donc en fait quand on regarde
un peu dans les détails depuis 30 ans le
nombre d'étudiants qui suivent un cursus
dans l'enseignement supérieur privé donc
à triplé atteignnant plus de de 20 % des
effectifs
aujourd'hui 3/4 donc 3/4 de ces
étudiants sont inscrits dans des
établissements qui sont placés quand
même dans l'orbite de sociétés
commercial comme des grands groupes
comme Holmes qui est détenu par un fond
d'investissement britannique vous avez
aussi Galileo qui est détenu par un fond
de retraite canadien et la holding de la
famille béancour Mayers mais en fait le
point aussi de cet essort du privé c'est
surtout dû principalement il faut
pouvoir faut le dire également à la
popérisation de l'université à laquelle
on n pas donné les moyens d'accueillir
un nombre croissant d'étudiants depuis
2010 euh il profite aussi se privé d'une
manne financière publique depuis la
réforme du système d'apprentissage en
2018 qui a vu exploser euh l'alternance
c'est aussi vous l'avez dit vous-même
vous y avez répondu tout à l'heure c'est
le résultat de l'anxiété qui est qui est
générée chez les lycéens et leurs
parents par le manque de transparence
qui entour le fonctionnement de parcours
sup et sur lesquels surf et vous l'avez
très bien dit justement euh le privé
donc la concurrence
déloyales que constitue le le secteur
privé lucratif à l'égard du public il
repose souvent et vous l'avez également
mentionné sur des pratiques commerciales
qui sont trompeuses on a la la direction
générale de la répression des fraudes
qui a révélé quand même qu'il y a plus
de 30 % des établissements privés
supérieurs qu'elle avait contrôlé qui
s'était avéré être en anomalie en
matière de pratique commerciales
trompeusees en 2020 des des mentions sur
l'employabilité postdplôme dépourvu de
toute justification vérifiable ou sur
des partenariats non formalisé avec des
grandes entreprises d'ailleurs je
recommande le rapport de la médiatrice
de l'éducation nationale que j'ai
parcouru et de l'enseignement supérieur
qui a fait état de 469 saisines
concernant le privé lucratif en 2022
vous avez par exemple des étudiants qui
qui découvrent tardivement que le
Bachelor ou le master qu'ils ont obtenu
qu'il prépare ne fait pas l'objet d'une
reconnaissance par l'État vous avez des
étudiants qui se voient refuser le
remboursement de leurs frais de
scolarité alors qu'ils n'ont pas pu
bénéficier de leur formation en raison
d'une grave maladie ou d'un refus
d'octroi du visa vous avez des étudiants
qui ne parviennent pas à récupérer leur
diplôme ou une attestation de réussite
parce que la société commerciale qui est
propriétaire de leur établissement a
tout simplement mis la clé sous la porte
parfois en cours d'année alors moi
j'aurais trois questions en fait parce
que ça ça a été abordé en partie mais
face au grand flou qui entoure ces
formations ça a été dit il y a la
ministre qui a annoncé la mise en place
d'une plateforme que vous avez que vous
avez évoqué pour réparorier les
formations publiques et les formations
privées qui bénéficiant d'une
reconnaissance par l'État alors vous
l'avez mentionné également vous avez
parlé d'un qu' qu'il fallait plus de
régulation nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord avec vous il faut il faut plus
de régulation en la matière alors
pourquoi justement laisser Prosp opérer
ces marchands de formation en
établissement cette fameuse labilisation
à postériori pourquoi ne pas la faire à
priori j'ai cru entendre cette piste
mais- ce que vous pourriez approfondir
par rapport à à à ce sujet-là j'ai une
autre question aussi c'est en lien avec
l'article
l731-14 du code de l'éducation qui qui
prévoit une sanction pécunière de 30000
€ pour le responsable d'établissement
qui donne à celui-ci le titre du
université ou fait décerner des
certificats portant le titre de
baccalauréat de licence ou de doctorat
est-ce qu'on ne devrait pas justement
prévoir des sanctions plus lourdes qui
frappent non seulement le chef
d'établissement mais aussi les
actionnaires de la société commerciale
qui on sont les les propriétaires et ma
troisème question c'est face au manque
de transparence sur sur lequel surf
justement ces établissements n n'est-il
pas le temps aussi peut-être d'exiger
que soit rendu public des données
concernant leur performance en terme
d'insertion professionnelle puisqu'ils
font ils en font souvent un argument de
vente sans aucune preuve vis-à-vis des
familles et des élèves
jeanr merci monsieur le Président
maintenant que l'ensemble des questions
on été posées par nos deux excellents
collègues Stéphane piennoir et Yan
chanrel il nous reste de répéter
quelques questions mais moi monsieur Cho
j'aurais voulu monsieur ch j'ur voulu
rebondir sur vos propos vos derniers
propos et vos propos introductifs qui
font aussi
écho à l'action de France université qui
a demandé des sanctions et une
clarification sur la dénomination des
établissements ainsi que sur les
intitulés des diplômes délivrés qui
doivent notamment ne pas faire référence
à tout ce qui est licence master et
doctorat la réelleincription des
diplômes délivré au répertoire
spécifique de France compétence devrait
être vérifié dans tous les dossiers de
demandes de Grad et de visas qu'en
est-il euh de plus il y a aussi une
demande de transparence totale sur la
structure financière et la gestion de
ces établissements et aussi une
évaluation dont les conclusions seraient
rendues publiques euh pour être effectué
aussi par une institution euh
indépendante j'aimerais avoir votre
position là-dessus le notre collègue Yan
Chantrel a parlé de sanctions moi j'ai
aussi euh euh cette question sur le bout
d'élèv faut-il des sanctions comme par
exemple l'exclusion euh de de certains
de certaines de certains établissements
de certains salons faut-il mettre en
place un code de déontologie et faut-il
aussi délivrer les chiffres sur
l'insertion professionnelle les
dernières questions aveé avez-vous été
auditionné par la Mission la Direction
Générale de l'Enseignement Supérieur et
de l'insertion professionnelle sur
l'enseignement supérieur privé lucratif
je vous remercie
pierreouyas merci monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup pour pour votre propos
qui est qui est extrêmement clair et on
voit on voit très bien que certaines
petites officines privé sont en train de
de développer un modèle qu'on pourrait
appeler celui de l'auto-entrepreneur de
sa formation considérer que chaque
chaque individu peut finalement bricoler
sa formation ce qui est la négation
complète du principe de cursus qui est à
la base de l'Université française depuis
le 13e siècle donc on est on est face à
un changement de paradigme qui est
extrêm important moi j'aimerais revenir
sur sur les propos de Monsieur
emrich qui est le le président de HES
éducation qui est détenu par un fond
d'investissement britannique lequel
possédait avant d'un Lop on passe on
passe des pneumatiques à à
l'enseignement et qui n'est pas
proprement parler une poof school comme
vous les appelez puisque c'est
l'Institut des hautres études
économiques et commerciale entre autres
et il explique de façon transparente que
dans la croissance fulgurante de de son
groupe il y a un tiers des des moyens
qui ont été apportés par l'apprentissage
donc la la croissance de de ce groupe
privé s'est fait sur sur fond public et
ensuite il a une analyse assez radicale
de ce que doit être l'enseignement
supérieur en considérant que finalement
il y a deux critères qui comptent le
premier c'est le taux d'obtention de
diplôme et le deuxième c'est le le taux
d'insertion professionnelle et il
considère que la recherche c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait accessoire et que
les enseignants doivent d'abord se
consacrer à la satisfaction de ces deux
choses et pas et pas de la recherche ce
qui pose un problème considérable pour
notre politique nationale de la
recherche qui est très déficiente par
rapport à nos concurrents
européens le principe de de la recherche
et celui que vous défendez enfin de
l'enseignement celui que vous défendez
c'est l'idée que l'enseignant est aussi
un chercheur et qu'on enseigne bien une
matière quand on recherche aussi dans
cette matière et là il y a une coupure
avec avec avec ce paradigme de
nouveau ça ça pose un énorme problème
national ce comme vous le savez on
manque d'ingénieur le nombre de de
diplômés de doctorat baisse chaque année
et on sent bien que là il y a toute une
partie des des jeunes qui pourraient se
diriger vers l'enseignement supérieur
qui vous échappe et qui échappe aussi
aux filières de la recherche donc on est
un train sur fond public d'appauvrir le
le vivier potentiel des chercheurs si on
continue comme ça on pourra parler de
nos deux derniers prix
Nobel tout à fait au passé parce que je
je pense que ça pose un un vrai problème
donc sur ces questions cursus et
recherches moi j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment merci monsieur le
Président Monique deco je vous remercie
et je vous remercie également pour cet
état des lieux moi je reviendrai sur ce
que je pense être le chînon manquant
c'est-à-dire celui de de renforcer
l'orientation des élèves non pas au
niveau du bac mais bien avant donc il y
a quand même un problème dans
l'éducation national c'est que faute
d'avoir suffisamment de conseillers de
conseillè d'orientation ce sont souvent
les enseignants qui conseill donc ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il serait bien aussi
d'appuyer sur ce fonctionnement
d'orientation qu'il y a au sein des
établissements avant le bac et ça j'y
pense depuis depuis même la la trisème
c'est-à-dire pas seulement en lycée
euh pourquoi parce qu'ensuite les jeunes
les familles se tournent justement vers
les salons vers Internet vers les PF
school bon je trouve ça assez parlant
comme comme appellation
ensuite je reviens sur ces fameux
critères qui pourrai être utilisés sur
cette plateforme vous avez parlé par
exemple éventuellement du taux
d'encadrement mais également d'éléments
très faciles à comprendre pour les
familles pouvez-vous préc prcis et
dernière question au final je ne sais
pas quelles sont les données que l'on a
globalement est-ce qu'il est facile
d'avoir donc des données précises sur
les étudiants qui s'orientent sur les
types de formation est-ce qu'il y a un
document qui qui précise toutes ces
données merci Bernard fiellerer
oui merci monsieur le Président bon non
plus je reprendrai pas tout tout ce qui
a été dit et toutes les les étude que
nous proposent ces ces différentes
officines d'enseignement la la question
quand même c'est où irait tous les tous
les étudiants tous les élèves qui sont
dans ces officines si on les fermait
toutes
comme on pourrait dans un monde absolu
le vouloir est-ce que vous avez la
capacité est-ce qu'on sait que d'abord
combien y en a est-ce que vous avez la
capacité d'accueil et de formation par
exemple pour pour tous ces jeunes
qu'est-ce qui limite euh votre off de de
place et puis est-ce que vous avez une
part de responsabilité quand même parce
que vous l'avez dit vous-même il y a des
branches professionnels qui ont souhaité
faire leur formation parce que elle
était pas sur le marché c'est-à-dire
parce que justement vous ne répondiez
pas à ces à ces formations après il y a
le problème quand même aussi de la
mixité sociale vous avez bien dit que
ça était recruté dans ces écoles plutôt
des gens qui étaient pas enfants de scp+
et cetera
quand on voit quand
même quand on voit les
résultats des des grandes écoles de
commerce par exemple où 80 % des AES
viennent de prépas privés qui sont à des
prix exorbitants on voit bien quand même
qu'il faut que certaines familles
s'orientent vers d'autres formations
hein puisque c'est presque
condamné condamnés à l'avance s'ils sont
pas capables si la famille a pas des
moyens de payer des formations qui sont
sont extrêmement chers on a les prix et
on a les résultats d'ailleurs des des
meilleures écoles de commerce donc
est-ce que le développement justement de
classe prépa intégré possibilité de
recrutement c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être développé et et quel est
le pourcentage justement de prépas
intégré dans dans vos écoles qui sont
pas toutes je pense à l'INSA c'est aussi
des écoles d'excellence qui qui passe
par des par des prépas intégrés euh donc
quel est quel est le pourcentage dans
vos écoles de prép intégré Samantha
casbonne oui merci monsieur le Président
al moi je toujours dans dans la
continuité des des prépages j'aimerais
partager un un témoignage et avoir votre
avis monsieur Choquet sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure moi moi je je suis
française de l'étranger et très
impliquée sur les lycées français à
l'étranger et je vois depuis quelques
années euh un un retrait totalement
assumé de la part de nos élèves euh vers
justement ces classes prépa alors que
nous avons des profils plutôt élitistes
he on va pas se mentir dans ces lycées
français et je suis assez sidérée et ça
reprend un petit peu ce que vous disiez
sur sur peut-être la la notion d'effort
aussi même dans des établissements
scolaires qui avaient cette vocation
vraiment à à pousser l'excellence à ne
plus intéressés par nos prépas en France
ces profils d'élèves qui sont d'ailleurs
mixtes hein puisque nous avons des
élèves
totalement français des deux parents
nous avons des binationaux et nous avons
des des étrangers et la plupart se
tourne aujourd'hui de ces profilsl
j'entends vers des modèles anglo-saxons
qui amènent à diversifier on va dire le
le le le les les compétences des élèves
et qui les tourne moins vers l'exigence
et et vraiment je je Ren compre
systématiquement ces élèves de terminal
et je suis frappée par cette évolution
et que je ne m'explique pas dans ces
lycées là autant je pourrais le
comprendre par ailleurs donc c'est pour
ça que j'aimerais un peu votre votre
regard parce que je je n'arrive pas à
comprendre l'origine si ce n'est un fait
de société qu'on qu'on constate tous de
voir ce ce recul face à l'effort mais du
coup qui a aussi des conséquences dans
nos lycées français qui tiraent par le
haut je dirais aussi notre enseignement
à l'étranger et aujourd'hui où je trouve
qu'il y a des voilà même ils assument
ces élèves là de dire bah non c'est trop
d'effort et et on va ailleurs vers
d'autres modèles
Maxon merci monsieur le Président je
mesure combien mon intervention va être
solitaire décalé y compris par rapport à
mon propre
groupe mais ENF le pluralisme et la
diversité sont le charme de notre
Sénat la première chose voudrais vous
dire vous avez fait un tableau qui
sépare le bien du mal
et dans lequel vous avez fléché ceux qui
sont lucratifs et ceux qui ne le sont
pas je suis pas sûr que tous les parents
qui inscrivent leurs enfants dans les
écoles de commerce consulaire est la
même version de ce qui est lucratif et
de ce qui ne l'est
pas deuxièmement comme vieux professeur
de casse préparatoire j'ai tellement
entendu les écoles de management vter le
fait que chez eux il y avait des
professionnels à diff universit
que chez eux il y avait un rapport à
l'entreprise tellement différent
d'université j'ai tellement entendu les
école de commerce dire que les
passerelles multiples permettaient
d'éviter les classes préparatoires où
l'on a prutissait par les formations
académiques j'ai tellement participé à
des juris de recrutement dans à des
juris dans les écoles de commerce où on
me disait bien clairement que les
formations académiques étaient obsolètes
et dépassé qu'il fallait être en phase
constante
avec l'entreprise pour me dire qu'il me
semble que l'arroseur est aujourd'hui
arrosé et qu'à force d'avoir tapé sur
les classes
préparatoires on se retrouve dans la
situation o on est aujourd'hui et donc
j'auris du mal à vous
plaindre l'université je vais pas
remonter au 13e siècle comme le
président
ouias mais au moins à bonapartte après
tout les écoles les unes après les
autres ont tout fait pour échapper
au monopole deuniversité notre système
c'est construit ainsi on a eu d'ailleurs
beaucoup de mal à l'expliquer aux
européens où finalement les meilleurs
des élèves n'allent pas à l'université
mais rentrer à l'école et rester des
élèves et ainsi c'est construit notre
système et la partie
gauche du tableau qui sépare le bien et
le mal c'est nourit là-dessus pendant
des
décennies donc moi je constate qu'on a
pêché et que l'on souffre aujourd'hui
par où on a largement pêché où on a
construit un système qui a affaibli
l'université nous avons eu monsieur le
Président Julias dans l'hémicycle des
débats sur le rôle des des
docteurs dans notre dans le mode de
recrutement de nos entreprises et la
place et le rôle des docteurs dans notre
pays on a ouvert la porte et beaucoup
s'en sont engouffrés alors une fois que
j'ai dit ça avec force il est évident
que je combats moi je utiliser
vocabulaire ancien vous êtes dans une
vieille maison les marchands de soupe je
les ai toujours combattu comme
professeur de classe préparatoire ils
ont toujours existé les marchant de
souous peut-être même dans la partie
gauche du du tableau qui sépare le bien
et le
mal et donc je suis bien d'accord avec
vous de la
nécessité de mettre de l'ordre dans tout
cela de réguler autant que faire ce peu
de contrôler de
sanctionner mais malgré tout de se poser
un certain nombre de questions vous avez
donné quelques
causes de cet essort remarquable un
étudiant aujourd'hui sur sur qu en
disant une progression de de 20 à 25
% il y a quelques
sujets d'abord de l'absence de certaines
formations dans la partie gauche du
tableau qui explique qu'on va Leser
chercher dans la partie droite à force
de pas vouloir être en phase avec des
évolutions de la société des métiers
ben le marché comble
l'absence lorsque le service public
n'est plus plus rendez-vous hein
excusez-moi de vous dire que s'il y a
certaines des écoles c'est que
l'université a parfois eu des peurs de
gazelle comme d'ailleurs elle le l'avait
dans la partie gauche du tableau entre
la partie orange et la partie bleue
et que si les écoles consulaires ont
existé c'est qu'il y avait le plus grand
mépris pour ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
les épiciers c'està-dire ce qui ce qui
se dirigeent vers les études de commerce
bon voilà c'est cette histoire là elle
est pas nouvelle et vous en avez votre
part de responsabilité une fois je vous
ai dit cela je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on se pose un nombre de questions sur
les causes de cet essort qu'on cherche
des voies de régulation mais qu'on se
dise
aussi que ce que vous appelé la liberté
d'entreprendre je l'appelle moi la
liberté d'enseignement et que c'est un
principe
constitutionnel David
Ross merci euh président euh merci
effectivement pour cette présentation
puis alors vu toutes les questions qui
ont été posées j'aurais quasiment pu
m'absonir mais finalement monre collègue
Brisson m'amène peut-être à réagir un
petit
peu il sem que la partie gauche saoné et
pêché sans jeu de mot c'est lui qui le
disait lui-même alors je sais pas si
aujourd'hui il s'agit de faire
rédemption mais en tout cas la vraie
question qui se pose c'est pas d'opposer
effectivement le public au privé c'est
d'abord la question du côté lucratif
lucratif c'est dire bénéfice donc à qui
va le bénéfice si le bénéfice va au
système de l'enseignement supérieur cela
me va bien s'il y a des actionnaires qui
ont d'autres intérêts ça pose question
alors moi ce que je trouve important en
tout cas dans sujet je sais pas si vous
pourrez répondre aujourd'hui ce serait
que vous puissiez nous quantifier par
rapport à tout ce que vous avez décrit
en fonction des filières notamment par
rapport aux sciences dures par rapport
au management par rapport à l'économie
est-ce que le phénomène est le même en
fonction des différentes filières de
voir s'il y a une évolution depuis le
covid et depuis aussi la mise en place
de parcours su ou dé parcours su parce
qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'évolution en la
matière et puis il y a la question ça a
été évoqué donc de la visibilité alors
vous avez dit
les les enfants ou non pas les enfants
les étudiants sont paumés les jeunes
sont paumés alors je pense qu'il y a pas
que les jeunes qui sont paumés vous avez
les parents qui sont paumés vous avez
aussi des acteurs de l'enseignement
supérieur et je sais de quoi je parle
qui sont aussi paumés et donc ça pose la
question plus globalement de la
visibilité et donc dans cette visibilité
à mon avis ça a été dit il y a la
question de la statistique c'est qu'il
faudrait qu'on puisse avoir accès sur
les statistiques dans la durée et avoir
des infographies qui soi soit par un
organisme indépendant soit par une
délégation interminist matériel validé
pour qu'on puisse avoir sur plusieurs
années cette infographie qui fait part
effectivement de des labels accordés de
l'efficacité en terme d'entrée et de
sortie et notamment sur le côté emploi
sur l'entrée ça pose plusieurs questions
puisque il y a le timing entre parcours
sup et les filières qui permettent de
sur dossier de recruter en amont il y a
ce que vous avez dit sur les manières de
détourner alors j'ai entendu vous
parliez de Madrid je sais que au Québec
aussi il y a beaucoup d'attentes ça doit
être pour aller voir notre collègue
Chantrel il y a aussi la manière de
détourner les prépas puisque au-delà des
prépas classiques il y a les prépas
intégrés ça a été évoqué par un collègu
mais il y a aussi et je sais de quoi je
parle les doubles licences qui marchent
très très bien à l'université notamment
Paris saclé et qui permet à des jeunes
tous les ans d'intégrer par exemple
l'École polytechnique il n'auraiit pas
intégré en faisant 3 ans de prépa et en
passant les 3 années de leur vie à ne
faire que ça je dis ça parce que ça nous
pose aussi la question même si on a
tendance à dire que les jeunes ont moins
envie de faire l'effort je pense qu'il
faut qu'on fasse attention à cela on met
derrière effort ce que nous faisions à
l'époque en prépa eux derrière effort il
mettre autre chose et donc il faut
peut-être aussi que les formations
intègrent ça si elles veulent pouvoir
exister et si le modèle des grandes
écoles qui a fait la force de la France
dans les formations des ingénieurs de
qualité puisse perdurer il va falloir
aussi qu'on puisse intégrer tout cela
donc tout ça pour vous dire que je pense
que la question d'infographie et la
capacité de donner des informations euh
pour moi est essentielle parce que les
parents sont quand même pas bêtes les
jeunes non plus et s'ils avaient des
messages clairs je pense aussi qu'ils
seraient s'en
nourrir et enfin Pierre-Antoine
Laville écoutez monsieur le Président
grande partie des des questions que je
souhaitais poser ont déjà été abordées
mais peut-être vous demander des
précisions sur comment les les
établissements privés en collaboration
avec le ministère d'enseignement
supérieur envisage-t-il de simplifier de
clarifier le système de reconnaissance
des programmes pour éviter la confusion
entre les labels vous en avez parlé les
accréditations délivrées par différents
ministères entités ça c'est une première
question et quelles stratégies seront
mises en œuvre pour assurer que leurs
diplômes et programmes soient non
seulement reconnus par l'État mais
également valorisé par les employeurs le
marché du travail et enfin au fait au vu
de tout ce qui a été dit sur les
sanctions sur le le on va dire le le
constat très précis de ce que vous avez
fait est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aurait besoin de faire une loi pour
interdire d'utiliser des diplômes
d'enseignement supérieur qui ne sont pas
dans le référen ancienne nationale pour
éviter les déconvenus de certains des
étudiants qui passent des concours et
s'aperçoit que leurs diplôme n'ont
aucune existence
officielle dernière intervenante Sonia
de la provuté oui merci beaucoup euh
monsieur le Président très
rapidement la la formation vétérinaire a
été autorisée dans un cadre dans le
cadre d'une école
privée sur la volonté de l'école
peut-être peut-être du public je n'en
sais rien encourager
peut-être et et ma question elle porte
en fait sur la
stratégie que vous développer au travers
de de cette conférence et à ce que dans
dans votre stratégie de
développement hormis le fait que vous
avez quand même à gérer toute cette
concurrence d'épiciers de boutiquiier de
je ne sais pas comment le disait max
prisson vous n'avez pas une stratégie
aussi d'aller sur tous les segments sur
lesquels le publ s'exprime et de façon
excellente pour finalement en parallèle
ou créer en miroir des formations qui
émanerit de vos écoles plus que du de de
de la sphère publique telle qu'on qu'on
la conçoit au travers de l'université ou
est-ce que cette stratégie là n'est pas
en tout cas elle n'est pas affichée dans
dans votre plan de de charge donc est-ce
que c'est c'est une volonté que vous
avez voilà je voulais vous laisser
répondre vous partageons peut-être les
différents thèmes et sujets abord euh
alors je vais essayer de répondre en
même temps à un ensemble de questions
enfin vu le nombre de questions
peut-être qu'on va passer la journée
ensemble c'est peut-être pas prévu merci
en tout cas de votre intérêt
euh sur la question il y a une question
sur la question de la régulation à
priori nous la régulation à priori c'est
ce qu'on vit et je vais prendre un
exemple qui concerne les formations
d'ingénieur moi je dirige les ARS et
Métiers je suis interrogé par un de vos
collègues sur un territoire qui me dit
j'ai des besoins dans le nucléaire
qu'est-ce que vous faites pour monter
rapidement une formation d'ingénieur
dans le champ nucléaire aujourd'hui je
lui répon mon système d'accréditation
fait que je ne peux pas ouvrir la
formation avant 2025 voilà le rythme des
accréditations pas ça ensuite je vais
devoir faire 3 ans de formation
d'ingénieur
2028 attendre 2 ans d'avoir sorti des
jeunes pour voir s'il est dans le
nucléaire pour avoir un titre RNCP 2030
et là je vais pouvoir commencer à
recruter les premiers en en sous le
statut d'apprenti et je vais sortir les
premiers apprentis en 2033 je vais faire
ça je vais avoir mis 10 ans pour
répondre à la demande de ces
collectivités et de ces entreprises donc
il y a clairement un manque d'agilité
dans notre
système ce système de régulation a
priori qu'on vit
voilà et il a il a un manque
d'agilité ce manque d'agilité d'où
est-ce qu'il vient bah effectivement de
de la qualité de ce qu'on cherche à
mettre dans lainformation il vient aussi
du fait que je dirige un établissement
public et qu'on va faire attention à
l'usage des fonds publics qu'il y a dans
mon établissement effectivement en face
de ça on a des établissements qui euh
ont une agilité que moi je n'ai pas et
donc du coup pour répondre à certaines
de vos questions qui ont la capacité de
monter dans la minute des formations en
s'appuyant sur un titre existant qui n'a
rien à voir mais comme il y a pas de
contrôle sur ce qu'on met derrière un
titre on l'a dit tout à l'heure on monte
on monte une formation management des
sports en s'appuyant sur un titre sur le
développement commercial ben ces gens-là
on les on les laisse monter très
rapidement et avec une qualité inconnu
des des des formations qui sont
potentiellement attractives parce que
semblant être plus au goût du jour donc
effectivement nous on milite euh pour
répondre à une autre question on a des
capacités on peut absorber ce flux dans
nos écoles je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
on milite pour plus d'agilité dans nos
établissements publics ou nos
établissements non publics sous contrat
pour pouvoir monter rapidement des
formations et qu'on fasse aussi
confiance à ce qu'on a fait avant et à
sur des formations qu'on a depuis
longtemps sur notre capacité à faire des
formations de qualité et qu'on ait un
petit peu de régulation à postériori
quand on est un établissement qui a qui
a pignon sur rue et qui et qui et qui
est sous sous contrat avec l'État ou qui
a un établissement un établissement
public euh je vais te laisser répondre à
quelques questions le temps de oui
peut-être en introduction
peut-être en introduction on n'est pas
en dehors du monde et notre enseignement
supérieur sur le moyen long terme il
faut le raisonner en fonction bah de
l'évolution de l'enseignement supérieur
dans lequel on doit se positionner et
qui entre nous soit dit est très
compétitif alors la réponse au aux
classe prépa justement elle s'inscrit
dedans c'estàd que notre modèle classe
prépa grandes écoles effectivement il
était un petit peu atypique par rapport
à ce qui se pratique au niveau européen
par rapport à ce qui se pratique au
niveau international et et on est dans
une évolution
de notre système enseignement sup par
rapport à à cette cet environnement
international si je si je reprends un
petit peu le voilà alors je ve pas dire
le bien et le mal parce que pour moi
c'est un continua mais j'ai bien mis
hors contrat et sous contrat je pense
que le privé il le privé dans
l'enseignement supérieur notamment le
privé àit non lucratif il il existe
depuis plus de 100 ans et et je pense
qu'il est positif à l' ignement
supérieur si tentz qu'il s'inscrivve
bien dans la même mission de service
public c'estàdire que onarrête pas de
prenner la biodiversité comme un élément
essentiel de résilience bah dans
l'enseignement sup aussi ça peut être
bien qu'il a un petit peu de de
stimulation positive si tantz que les
gens répondent au même cahiier des
charges aux mêmes exigences et au quel
cas l'État pour piloter son enseignement
supérieur à des établissements publics
des établissements privés sous contrat
qui remplissent la même mission
qui ont des approches différentes et qui
s'autostimulent l'une et l'autre donc
pour moi ça me semble très important et
et le meilleur exemple en est c'est mon
ministère d'origine qui est le ministère
de
l'Agriculture voilà où historiquement il
y a toujours eu cette équilibre où o où
Michel Rocard a mis en place la loi
Rocard reconnaissant la mission de
service public avec un financement qui
permet un réel
fonctionnement alors par rapport à
l'école vétérinaire ça je su je suis
directement concerné puisque c'est c'est
mon école qui l'a amené c'est à la
demande du ministère de l'Agriculture
qui en voilà en 2008 où on a commencé à
mener cette réflexion parce qu'on savait
qu'on était dans le mur en terme de
formation vétérinaire pour les médecins
aussi et pour les médecins aussi alors
bon je pour l'instant je m'occupe de
vétérinaire il y a il y a une offre une
offre de formation qui voilà il y a il y
avait un besoin énorme bon
malheureusement il a fallu 14 ans pour
que le dossier aboutisse qu' faire le le
délai aujourd'hui on est à 55 % des
vétérinaires qui s'inscrivent à l'ordre
qui ont obtenu leur diplôme à l'étranger
et on se dit barbe tout il a il y a un
flux qui s'est créé à l'étranger qu'on
ne maîtrise plus dommage qu'on nit pas
tué le poussin dans l'œuf parce que si
on avait créé l'école vétérinaire
associative en 2008 on aurait
certainement pas ce problème et tout
serait sous contrôle he et et comme par
hasard le ministère de l'agriculture
comme il y a davantage équ public privé
on est moins attaqué attaqué par le
privé hab lucratif voilà parce que
l'ensemble des des besoins sont
satisfaits et il y a pas de difficulté
par rapport à ça mais encore faut-il que
l'enseignement supérieur privé d'intérêt
général voilà et les moyens de
fonctionner et les moyens de développer
des activités de recherche en
complémentarité avec l'activité
recherche qui est faite dans à
l'université je reviens un peu par
rapport à la lisibilité et les diplômes
on a' dit oui attention au diplôme alors
je vais prendre l'exemple voilà euh les
écoles d'ingénieur d'harmonisation
européenne et internationale les écoles
d'ingénieurs sont autorisées à délivrer
un diplôme bac + 5 depuis très longtemps
avec le système LMD nous revendiquions
Laib ibité de délivrer un bac+ 3 voilà
donc le ministère a dit d'accord vous
pouvez délivrer un bac + 3 niveau
licence ah oui mais on peut pas
l'appeler licence quand bien même on est
évalué par l' CHS organisme indépendant
par la Commission du titre d'ingénieur
organisme indépendant ah non on
l'appelle pas licence on va l'appeler
Bachelor conférent le grade de licence
aller expliquer ça à des parents il ne
pige rien voilà donc on est aussi
victime voilà les diplômes nationaux
sont le monopole de l'État pas pas des
universités il y aurait peut-être alors
quand je dis ça c'est voilà je c'est un
sujet très polémique donc j'irai pas
plus loin aujourd'hui mais quand il y a
un système d'évaluation extérieur voilà
si on veut aller faire une clarification
on peut-être pourrions-nous simplifier
le système des diplômes et et de leur
visibilité une petite remarque aussi
c'estàdire que quand on dit les ESP
privé à but reconnu d'intér général il
faut savoir que notre structure de
financement et notre mode de
fonctionnement est très similaire aux
universités publiques américaines donc
en fait c'est quoi université publique
alors je suis pas pour le privé les
établissements privés américains qui
facturent des frais de scolarité énorme
mais les établissements publics
américains les land Grand Collège les
les très vieux là qui ont été créés en
1852 ont un mode de financement et un
mode une autonomie de fonctionnement
très similaire au Espig et quand je leur
dis qu'en France on est considéré comme
privé il pouffent un peu de rire parce
que parce que eux voilà ils sont publics
reconnus comme publics et et et
intervenant donc je pense que
l'évolution dans la reconnaissance des
Espig est très positive notamment sur
les activités de recherche dans la
dernière loi de programmation de la
recherche comme ça ça nous inscrit
vraiment comme des acteurs euh de la
recherche publique et complètement
inscrit dans mission de service
public je continue tu quelques éléments
oui juste quelques éléments donc oui on
a été auditionné par la mission de la DG
EP hein et et on sera auditionné la
semaine prochaine par euh la mission de
de l'Assemblée nationale sur sur ce
sujet-là euh sur la question vous avez
posé beaucoup de questions sur la
question de de la diffusion de résultats
d'insertion alors l'insertion
professionnelle de nos étudiants fait
partie des critères de nos
accréditations donc on a ces
informations les universités ont ces
informations nous en particulier alors
c'est assez compliqué de capitaliser ces
informations nous la Conférence des
grandes écoles on aide les écoles en
faisant une enquête insertion tous les
ans depuis plus de 30 ans et on diffuse
ces résultats donc on a des données
claires par les enquêtes qu'on fait sur
les trois dernières promotions donc avec
et qui montre en particulier aujourd'hui
le très fort attrait qu'il y a pour nos
pour nos diplômés de la part des
entreprises alors sur la question de
l'arroseur arrosé et et de l'opposition
université grandes écoles bon nous on a
des moi j'ai une je dirige une école qui
a le même statut qu'une université donc
je me sens quand même dans le champ dans
le champ de l'université l'idée qu'on
défend à la Conférence des grandes
écoles c'est qu'il y a pas d'opposition
entre les deux systèmes on dit
simplement qu'en France on a des grands
systèmes euh publ ouvert à tous que sont
la santé l'éducation ainsi de suite et
qu'il faut un système universitaire
ouvert à tous pour pour pour traiter
pour former des jeunes pour ça et à côté
on a des entreprises privées qui ont un
mode de fonctionnement différent et nous
nos organisations d'école est plus
calqué sur cette organisation
d'entreprise privées sélectif à l'entrée
voilà et on dit qu'on a coexistence des
deux systèmes avec des passerelles qui
sont nombreuses ça c'est un élément
qu'on dit jamais assez concernant le
traumatisme parcours sup il y a
différents modèles de formation dans
l'enseignement supérieur aujourd'hui il
y a des modèles très académiques à
l'université il y a des modèles qui sont
plus entre un mélange d'académique et de
professionnel pour répondre à Monsieur
oui il y a des professionnels dans nos
formations mais il y a un équilibre
entre académique et professionnel et on
essaie d'être après à 50 % d'académique
à 50 % de professionn n en fonction de
des accréditations nécessaires euh il y
a des formations qui sont très
professionnalisantes et c'est souvent le
cas pour ça et c'est très bien c'est
difficile pour un jeune de savoir en
sortant d'un lycée en sortant du lycée
quel sera l'environnement le meilleur
pour lui mais on constate aujourd'hui
qu'il y a des passerelles qui sont très
nombreuses et on ne dit pas assez que
quand on clique quand on fait un choix
un parcours on fait pas un choix pour
toute la vie que l'année prochaine on
peut changer et rebasculer avec une très
grande réussite voilà donc nos systèmes
le fait qu'on soit en particulier sous
contrat sousétat fait que on y a des
passerelles importantes entre entre les
différents systèmes et et ça m'amène à
la question de la recherche oui c'est
vrai dans un champ très très académique
très universitaire c'est fondamental
d'avoir une recherche et en particulier
une recherche très à mon qui est qui est
fondamentale pour les évolutions de la
société dans nos écoles on fait aussi de
la recherche très à mon mais on va
chercher à s'intéresser justement à
comment est-ce qu'on transfère vers les
entreprises et comment est-ce qu'on crée
de la valeur comment qu'on crée de
l'emploi via la recherche et
l'innovation alors peut-être
qu'effectivement dans certaines filières
très professionnalisantes du supérieur
il y a peut-être pas besoin de cet
environnement cet environnement de
recherche mais nous on préfère le le
voir sur la question de à quoi ça sert
pour les entreprises on a récemment
intégré à la Conférence des grandes
écoles des des structures qui n'en
faisaient pas partie comme en
particulier des
écoles qui forment au métier de de
bouche LIF et puis euh F ferandi ces
écolesl diplôme à niveau bac+ 3 elles
forment quand même des gens qui seront
des cadres qui vont créer des
entreprises qui vont diriger des
entreprises et ces écoles-là ils font
une recherche qui est peut-être pas
publiante mais ils font au moins de
l'innovation et il crée de l'innovation
dans ses entreprises donc il y a sans
doute des éléments pas forcément au sens
de recherche académique publiante
nobélisable mais au sens de innovation
comment est-ce qu'on crée comment est-ce
qu'on crée de la valeur on continue à
créer de la valeur comment est-ce qu'on
répond au besoins de la société dans
toutes sortes d'entreprises et ces
éléments là il faut les prendre en
compte dans l'environnement de formation
de ces de ces futurs CAD vas-y je te
repasse la parole
oui éventuellement je je reviendrai
vontier sur la dimension de cursus et et
recherche voilà c'est vrai que la la
dimension de cursus formation de base et
possibilité d'évoluer bon ça c'est ce
que nous amené là un petit peu la la
réforme de l'enseignement supérieur au
niveau européen les crédits ECTS et ça
ça me semble être quelque chose
d'essentiel et et les cursus aussi par
rapport à des métiers voilà de pouvoir
construire un parcours donc c'est vrai
que c'est les les structures les titres
RNCP en fait sont des accumulations de
certificat ou de compétences et ne vont
pas vers ces logiques en fait de
d'acquisition de crédit CS et de et de
parcours sur lequel on peut capitaliser
pour aller vers un un titre
universitaire la la dimension recherche
je je pense que pour moi c'est vraiment
un un marqueur
important de ce qu'est l'enseignement
supérieur par rapport à de
l'enseignement professionnel qui est
louable et et je pense que dans les
années qui viennent avec tout ce qui va
arriver l'intelligence artificielle tous
ces éléments là en fait c'est la la
recherche comme dynamique pour un
secteur économique mais la recherche
aussi comme comme mode de formation
c'est la formation par la recherche
développer un esprit
critique avoir un regard sur ce qui ce
qui nous entoure je pense que nos nos
nos futurs ingénieurs nos futurs
responsables
en école de commerceà si si on ne les
initie pas à cet esprit critique qui est
favorisé par la recherche demain on on
sera en grande difficulté on se fera
voilà concurrencer par d'autres par
d'autres pays qui auront eux misé en
fait sur cette recherche et cette
formation par la recherche qui demain
sera essentielle essentielle on on est
plus dans une logique de transmission de
connaissance parce que il y a eu
Internet et là on va passer à
l'intelligence artificielle et ces
structures pourront faire des des choses
formidables en terme de trans trans
missission de connaissance par contre la
formation des des personnes leur
capacité à
évoluer leur capacité à se poser des
questions essentielle pour l'avenir donc
derrière ça c'est quelle vision on a de
notre enseignement supérieur dans les
années qui viennent alors que oui on va
se on va on va entrer dans des zones de
turbulence et ça je le dis hein on a
déjà on est déjà entré turbulence liée
effectivement un secteur très compétitif
et compétitif aussi venant des
États-Unis et tout ça enfin je veux dire
où il y a une financiarisation beaucoup
plus que chez nous même si là là-bas il
y a eu plutôt un feu de paille des
structures privées à lucratif hein et ça
s'est rapidement éteint parce qu'en fait
il il y avait pas de financement public
la différence chez nous c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un financement
public qui fait que le privé habit
lucratif ne resque pas enfin le feu de
paille risque de durer un peu plus
longtemps ce sera peut-être un feu de
bois quoi hein donc donc attention par
rapport à ça mais c'est quoi notre
vision de l'enseignement supérieur
demain et je pense que voilà le le
l'État doit avoir une vision et pas pas
que
courtermiste doit avoir une vision de
l'enseignement supérieur versus
enseignement purement professionnel même
si dans nos établissements je le redis
et c'est la richesse de voilà des
établissements sous contrat c'est qu'on
a des établissements il y a un un
gradient de d'établissements plus ou
moins professionnalisant et les grandes
écoles ont cette caractéristique d'être
davantage professionnalisant peut-être
que l'université même si l'université
progresse beaucoup et et on s'en réjou
he et et et je pense qu'on est ensemble
par rapport à ça donc voilà importance
d'avoir une vision de ce que doit être
l'enseignement supérieur
demain un élément sur sur l'orientation
euh vous avez tout à fait raison on a
vraiment une problématique d'orientation
alors c'est vrai que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous souvent la question
de l'orientation est reportée sur les
enseignants nous dans les premières
années de parcours su on a parcours sup
on a beaucoup milité pour que le
calendrier n'aille pas plus loin que la
date de fermeture des établissements
parce qu'effectivement les jeunes avent
avit besoin de leurs enseignants et des
professionnels
d'orientation on constate qu'il y a des
il y a beaucoup d'heures d'orientation
aujourd'hui avec une utilisation qui est
un peu disparate on nous précise que
nous établissement public on peut
s'impliquer dedans
euh on a du mal à voir comment dégager
le du temps de nos enseignants
chercheurs pour aller faire de
l'orientation donc c'est assez compliqué
pour nous donc effectivement aujourd'hui
on a on a vraiment une problématique
d'orientation et qui peut peut-être
effectivement par rapport à d'autres
questions qu'on a abordé hein vous posez
la question de de l'exigence de la
notion d'effort nous on voit aujourd'hui
comme on l'a dit plusieurs fois que les
enfin les enjeux des de transition
écologique
environnementale vont rendre les métiers
beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué hein
que ça soit dans le champ de
l'ingénierie des besoins d'interaction
beaucoup plus fortes on on va avoir
besoin de manipuler beaucoup d'outils
pour répondre à ces enjeux-l et on a
besoin de jeunes euh on dit il faut faut
que les jeunes veulent des formations
qui ont du sens il faut aussi qu'on leur
explique et c'est je pense que c'est un
des éléments deentation que euh on va
attendre beaucoup d'eux et qu'il faut
qu'ils soi capable de faire des efforts
pour ces questionsl et que ces cette
face C cette capacité à faire des
efforts ils vont la développer pendant
leurs
études euh quelqu'un a posé la question
de la mixité sociale euh alors il est
clair que on a dans on a pas assez de
mixité sociale dans nos
écoles l'apprentis sage est un très fort
outil d'ouverture sociale aujourd'hui il
y a aucune barrière technique ou
financière pour qui que ce soit pour
rejoindre n'importe laquelle de nos
grandes écoles on a parlé de frais de
scolarité c'est vrai qu'il y a des
écoles qui ont des frais de scolarité
importants mais qui restent quand même
très très largement inférieur à ce qu'on
peut trouver ailleurs dans le monde et
en particulier en Amérique du Nord et on
a dans nos écoles tous les mécanismes
d'accompagnement pour faire que ces
jeunes-là puissent venir dans nos écoles
que ça soit à travers nos no fondations
que ça soit sous forme d'apprentissage
les barrières elles sont culturelles
voilà et il faut qu'on lutte contre ces
barrières culturelles on a des barrières
culturelles sur le fait que les jeunes
femmes ne vont pas faire des études
d'ingénieur et on les barèr culturell
pour faire que des des jeunes issus
catégories moins
favorisé n'aillent pas dans dans dans
des grandes écoles euh c'est sans doute
de notre faute on y travaille tout
toutes nos écoles ont des ce sont on
placer des enjeux forts en terme de
mixité sociale en terme de diversité au
sens extrêmement large du terme mais on
avance doucement et il y a des barrières
culturelles qui remontent sans doute
vous l'avez dit au collège alors
peut-être avant
mais sur sur un milieu qui est très
atomisé sur lequel on a du mal à voir
comment est-ce que nous on peut on peut
intervenir
efficacement juste je pas encore le
peut-être un un un petit mot pour vous
dire aussi par rapport à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur la
complémentarité publ et éces associative
du mode de financement des écoles
associatives qui peut quelque part à mon
sens c'est est assez vertueux c'est dire
que les écoles associatives en fait ont
comme financeur en fait doivent rendre
des comptes à l'État aux familles et aux
entreprises l'état parce qu'on a on est
en contrat on reçoit une petite
subvention de fonctionnement alors qu'on
aimerait supérieur notamment pour les
activités de recherche et donc on a des
comptes à rendre à l'état pour démontrer
qu'on s'inscrit bien dans la mission de
service public les familles participent
au au frais de fonctionnement alors à
hauteur peut-être de 50 % du couré parce
que les coûts des écoles ESP comme elles
sont certifiées par la CTI avec des
exigigences encadrement on a des coûts
de fonctionnement alors du fait de notre
mode de fonctionnement un peu moins cher
que dans que dans le public mais elles
sont assez similaires convergentes les
familles contribuent à hauteur peut-être
de 50 % 60 % des coûts réels donc on a
des comptes à rendre aux familles je
trouve ça normal voilà et il nous manque
allez 5 10 % c'est nos contrats de
recherche qu'on a avec les entreprises
et et et si on n pas ces 5 % euh de de
de financement par les entreprises ben
en fait on néquilibre pas notre budget
donc on est obligé d'être à l'écoute de
notre de nos partenaires qui demain
voilà embaucheront nos élèves de nos
partenaires qui nous projettent dans la
recherche et les leur réflexion
recherche donc ça nourrit aussi nos
activités de chercheurs et le dernier
point aussi qui est assez assez
caractéristique notamment des
écoleshalisique c'est qu'on a une une
couverture territoriale assez large au
niveau français hein avec des écoles qui
sont implantées dans des villes quelque
fois de taille moyenne où il y avait pas
d'école d'ingénieurs et donc les
collectivités locales parce que nous
sommes exp peu finance peuvent financer
une partie de nos infrastructures et
donc on a des compte à rendre aux
collectivités locales et et quelque part
ça inscrit aussi dans notre mission de
service public le fait qu'on s'implique
localement qui dans des incubateurs qui
dans dans des politiques de pôle de
compétitivité et cetera hein donc ça et
et ce mode de fonctionnement où on a des
comptes à rendre à ces différents
parties prenante voilà me me me semble
être important peut-être un un petit
point par rapport au prépa outreemè
voilà que que j'ai pas évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que le le système
classe préparatoire aujourd'hui reste
un une machine très intéressante de
sélection aussi de formation c'est vrai
que par rapport à des à des jeunes
aujourd'hui ça correspond peut-être plus
au modèle des qu'attendent les jeunes
par rapport à l'enseignement supérieur
et à force Yi sans doute des jeunes qui
sont en outrem voilà parce que venir en
métropole et être complètement coupé
c'est pas c'est pas facile et d'autant
plus qu'ils sont
sollicités pour aller faire leurs études
au Canada où il y a pas cette ces
classes préparatoires donc faire
attention au stratégie d'évitement des
jeunes qui sont là-bas et peut-être leur
proposer des cursus avec prê intégré qui
sont tout autant d'excellencein au
niveau national et et intégré par
rapport à ça ça c'était la réponse par
rapport aux classes prpA d'outr mè
cétait aussi sur les les Français de
l'étranger pas Françis l'étrangers
pardon oui c'est pas que outrevert
pardon mais mais ça ça relève de la même
logique en fait hein parce que de voilà
quand quand un jeune français est en
Éthiopie ou en Chine et qu'il qu'il est
loin de ses parents de sa famille la
classe Préa peut être très dur sauf
avoir des prédispositions et au quel cas
c'est voilà ils seront remarquables mais
mais c'est mais c'est quand même
dur moi juste pour finir de mon côté il
y a une question sur la sur les amendes
euh oui peut-être voilà il y a
effectivement des dispositifs qui sont
en place je pense qu'on les utilise peu
c'est très bien que la DGCCRF et est
enquêté on a l'impression que les gens
peuvent toujours un peu jouer sur les
mots et pour échapper à l'amand et se
positionner un petit peu en dehors du
cadre donc la notion de reconnaissance
par l'État par exemple aujourd'hui elle
est utilisée un peu dans tous les sens
on sait pas trop pourquoi donc on n'est
pas vraiment sûr que le que le que les
amendes soient une bonne formule la
question du code de déontologie je pense
que c'est quelque chose plus intéressant
à à creuser euh qui peut sans doute
faire avancer les choses sur lequ on
peut on peut faire des contrôles voilà
je pense que juste av une question sur
la quantification du
phénomène c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui sur
les filières d'ingénierie il y a quand
même un système d'accréditation de titre
d'ingénieur qui fait que il y a pas de
dérive sur ce champ là alors il y a des
gens qui sont au bord dans plutôt dans
les champs du numérique aujourd'hui
parce qu'il y a un gros
attrait mais on voilà c'est vraiment
beaucoup sur le champ du commerce de la
culture qu'on voit qu'on voit plus des
dérives et c'est clair que ces écolesl
elles ont un modèle ultra léger donc
elles peuvent pas s'encombrer de
matériel pour faire des travaux
pratiques pour choses comme ça qu'on va
retrouver dans les diplômes
d'ingénieur av la question
éventuellement aussi de modification
complément de la loi puisquon est au 10
an de la loi fiorasso est-ce que de
votre point de vue il y a besoin de de
toucher à la
loi moi je pense que oui surtout pour
aller dans le sens de
l'agilité dans le sens des partenariat
public privé euh ça a été dit
aujourd'hui ça paraît assez clair que
certaines universités ne peuvent pas
investir sur certains champs nouveaux
parce qu'elles ont déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de travail peut-être qu'un
adossement bien clair surveillé avec une
structure privée qui pourrait
éventuellement
investir on voit qu'une banque comme BPI
France investit dans certaines
structures elle pourra investir dans les
structures privées qui soient adossé à
les établissements publics et de manière
efficace donc il y a sans doute un
travail à faire du côté de la
loi et sachant que l'exemple de la loi
existe au ministère de l'agriculture
avec la loi Roca on pour dire
effectivement l'étape suivante serait de
de garantir la mise en uvre de cette
mission de cette mission de service
public par les établissement qui
s'inscrivent dans cette logique là voil
peut-être réguler un petit peu plus tout
ce qui est création de des structure
d'enseignement supérieur professionnel
sur tire merci de vos réponse à nos
nombreuses questions bien sûr nous
allons continuer de suivre cette
problématique n manquons pas quand nous
la recevons aussi d'interroger la la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
pour connaître son son point de vue
au-delà de ses déclarations de de
septembre voir aussi comment l'État
travaille en interministériel parce que
on a bien compris à travers vos vos
remarques que l'Inter il y a pas qu'un
interlocuteur côté état mais il y a il y
a aussi le ministère du Travail qui à
travers les crédits form professionnelle
joue un rôle désormais important sur la
la question du financement de ces de ces
officines merci beaucoup messieurs les
président et donc chers collègues on se
retrouve à 16h45 à l'issue des des QAG
non pas dans cette salle mais en salle
M6 pour l'audition de Gabriel
àal monsieur